[Music]
all right we are live on the YouTube and
joining me today is a youtuber a
fearless defender of free speech and
someone people have very strong opinions
about it even says that in her Twitter
bio Blair White welcome to the Rubin
report thank you for having me I can't
believe we have not done this in part we
have never met in person but no and
we've tried like a million even not even
just the show but just like to hang out
with try we've tried for dinners we've
tried for coffee we've tried other times
to make this happen in person alright
well then there's a lot of pressure on
us yeah yeah for sure it has to be good
are you feeling the pressure I'm fine I
feel that pressure doesn't really affect
you it doesn't you know I watch your
videos you like it's just you strike me
as someone that's clear in your thinking
and you don't care what people think I
know that's sort of a cliched thing to
say about people but you really strike
me as that yeah I mean Contras the way
I've always been is you know I care
about how my immediate family things how
my boyfriend thinks but when it comes to
youtube I feel like you have to have
that thick skin so I'm kind of just
always talked about yeah right alright
so for people who know nothing about you
now we did do this once on skype and I
don't want to just repeat everything
that we did for an hour but I think
telling a little bit of your backstory
is good and then we can get to the to
the stuff that you really like talking
about so for the people that just have
no idea who you are or know nothing
about your background who is Blair White
where White is a youtuber I do social
and political commentary and I guess I'm
known for some inflammatory videos you
know covering controversial topics that
kind of a thing but at the end of the
day I'm just having fun with it you know
what I mean this living and I'm doing
different kind of content lately I'm
doing more lifestyle stuff more vlogs
more stuff about me because you know
YouTube's kind of changing how it is
right now all the roles any stuff going
on on YouTube could that be really
absolutely it's getting harder and
harder to do social and political
commentary for sure I mean you know know
the struggle I mean my channel luckily
hasn't been hit as hard as a lot of
other people that I'm friends with you
you know whatever youtubers and friends
with yeah but I'm feeling the pinch too
it's hard yeah it's kind of weird too we
were just saying before we started it's
like your titles of your videos
I mean you do what you want to do you
title things the way you want to title
them the thumbnails that you put up or
the way you want to do it
I try to play I think a little more by
the traditional YouTube rules but
clearly there doesn't seem to be a known
answer there that's what's crazy as
you're playing by the rules and you're
getting like in trouble for it and I'm
kind of breaking them and I'm fine yeah
but by the way I should mention on the
wide shot you might be able to see Emma
is in studio today this is our first
ever live shoot with Emma in Studio m
are you gonna say that
yeah Emma's in studio she was sitting
here right before we started and you
were like I was the dog gonna stay yeah
I said keep it and then you said keeper
so Emma's Emma's hanging if she starts
really saying hi she said hi all right
but let's not get too distracted but
yeah all right so I don't want to only
talk about trans issues obviously and
I'm sure at some level you've got to be
tired of talking about them in certain
ways not really not no I mean it's a
little interesting stuff I mean there's
still so much of it is still a huge
debate and so much of the science is
still you know not out so it's like it's
I guess it gets a little old sometimes
but I'm them before it today yeah all
right all right then let's do it so
let's just do a couple of minutes on
just your own journey when did you
realize that you were trans well I
realized I was different when I was very
young when I was probably in
kindergarten or so didn't really relate
to you know boys in my class didn't
really relate to the girls either but I
didn't really have the language to
describe what that meant until I was
probably a little older and maybe
fifteen sixteen and even that I went
through a huge denial phase and where I
didn't do anything about it but I wanted
to you I wasn't until about age 20 when
I had the means just within myself as an
adult to kind of you know take my life
into my own hands and make the changes I
wanted yeah so I read an interesting
thing this morning when I was doing some
research on you that when you were
realizing this around 1516 your father
passed away from cancer when you were 18
and that actually delayed your
transition because you didn't want your
mom to have to deal with with losing two
people in her life so yeah that's that
fascinating I mean that's deep that's
the yeah
yeah my dad passed away when I was 19 of
cancer it was very very unexpected and
when someone passes away especially you
know in the media
remember it kind of holds your life
regardless no matter what you're doing
so of course you know my transition was
definitely you know put on the back
burner because I didn't really want to
put my mom through losing her husband
and then all of a sudden like oh by the
way you're gonna lose your son to you
and you know he didn't lose me but it
was just a huge change and when someone
dies it's already a huge change so I
kind of took that into account yeah did
you did your mom know that you were at
least identifying a transit that point
like was it just the idea that you were
trying to not talk to her about at that
point or was it actually the transition
you know you mean like that you didn't
want her to it was the physical change
that was going to be the the real loss
here I guess it was the physical change
it was I mean a lot goes into it it's
like a name change it's like a pronoun
change it's everything so it's kind of
like you know the identity is kind of
shifting so it was kind of everything I
didn't want her to have to deal with it
it was just so much already she's going
through yeah so as someone that's gone
through the transition and we're going
to talk a little bit about some of the
surgeries that you've had recently and I
watched your videos and you were talking
about some of the the pain and the
experience of going through the stuff
that you couldn't have imagined had you
not done it what do you make of how much
we talk about trans issues now like you
know when there's this whole LGBTQ thing
and we did the gay rights thing for a
couple years and gay people got equality
which is the whole point we're supposed
to have equal opportunity okay that
we've sort of shifted the discussion now
to trans people do you view that as good
bad and different um it's a double sided
sport because I feel like when I look
back you know on the existence of trans
people maybe just in the last past
decade certain things have gotten better
but certain things have gotten worse
more people are more involved in the
conversation and so there's a lot of
unnecessary stuff flying around and so
it's almost like it was easier and
people didn't really know about it
because I mean I think everyone always
knew like oh there are some people who's
you know change their bodies or whatever
but now that everyone's so involved in
the debate there's just so much back and
forth it's unnecessary like it like the
bathroom thing that's unnecessary to be
for the most part yeah meaning what so
what's your take on the bathroom thing
well it's just like I've it's not real
life like I I don't like being expected
to like suspend my knowledge of how the
real world
works to have these debates because
because I've never had an issue using
any bathroom I want I just never have um
so it's like it's about understanding
people's concerns but also feeling okay
it's not a real concern or it's not that
bad you know
yeah it's so much understand unnecessary
stuff do you think maybe for you that's
a little bit unique in the trans
community because of the way you look
you know I mean so I know people talk
about someone that's passable or or
you're beautiful in this case so it's
like nobody is nobody's looking at you I
think or maybe the most Kenai who's
thinking about this all the time you
know vidiian but I don't think so I
don't think anyone's looking at you and
thinks thank you yeah so that in this
way you don't have to think about that
specific problem so much because you are
more it is passable the right word I
guess that I don't care about where it's
that much in that regard I guess that's
right yeah I suppose it is I suppose
that if I was six feet tall or whatever
it wouldn't be as easy you know what I
mean but at the same time you know a lot
of people talk about rapes and the
bathrooms and mall stations and the
bathrooms and it's just it's just not a
thing there's no facts to back it up
there's no statistics to back it up so
that part I get annoyed with that's
where the only part though yeah it's one
of those things that when we had that
whole brouhaha about what happened it
was like well trans people have been
going to the bathroom of their choice
for all this time yeah there didn't seem
to be an issue so now we've got the left
in this case screaming about an issue
that didn't exist and then you do have
sir made an issue so now we you've
created an issue where for me yes as a
small government guy well now you want
the government to come in and tell you
know cut funding for places that don't
do this and that with the bathroom and
all that but there is a genuine group of
other people and in this case they're
more on the right maybe maybe a
conservative Christian right or whatever
that is that do have some issue with
trans people right absolutely and you
know what I'm incredibly as long as they
are not putting their hands on me or
cruel I'm absolutely sympathetic to that
because I have the people in my family
yeah my mom started the family was
definitely more on the liberal side and
they've been very very accepting my dad
side it's been something different it
you know a lot of people on my dad's
side of the family I'm more on the
conservative side which is fine you know
I lean right as well but when it comes
to the trans thing they just they didn't
get it especially at first yeah and so
for me it was about learning to be
patient with those people which is
I feel like that kind of bleeds over to
my online presence is what those people
you know I'm able to interact with them
and it's like it's fine you know yeah I
love that because that's what it's all
about right like you took people who
knew you as as one thing now know you
something else and even if they
struggled with it or even if you
probably have some people that still
struggle with it in your family right at
some level maybe absolutely there's
still turmoil on that end it's not crazy
extreme or anything you know not
something I think about every day but
it's still there
and so you know I think that a lot of
the times when it comes to trans people
they sort of have the wrong mindset when
it comes to family I mean I can't judge
every situation but I feel like if you
want someone to be patient and
understand you and come to learn about
you and your thoughts and your beliefs
and who you are you have to do the same
it's a two-way street so a lot of trans
people get caught up in like being very
very defensive and like if you don't
accept me on every single term then you
can't be in my life which it's that
because family is everything you know I
can't throw people away and I used to
see that you know before I was doing
this in what seems like another life for
me I was on the LGBT channel on Sirius
XM I wanted to do politics but I was gay
so they're like you'll do a gay show gay
guy yeah I was on that and I would come
across or I'd interview a lot of times
that type of person who you know gay
people didn't have equal rights I
obviously wanted gay people to have
equal rights but that type of person who
was so strident in removing all of these
people from their lives making it seem
that they're all bigots and all that
stuff and it's like that's not how you
change mind and that's the kind of
advice a lot of the advocates have gay
act gay advocates as well um and it's a
very toxic because family is everything
you can't just throw people away
you have to just meaning in the middle
you know do you see that as a
interesting paradox of all this that I I
agree with you I think family and
friends are far more important than what
larger society is going to say about you
certainly what the government is gonna
say about you you know again you want
the equal rights but there's like a
certain strange thing there where
they're trying to almost replace the
family with some of the the social
justice stuff like that should be your
new family because they know everything
about you
by the way they think it should be
absolutely and I've talked about this on
my channel how when I was younger like
15 16 17 I was very heavily involved in
social justice circles and everything
and there definitely is this aspect of
like this is your new
this is your new tribe and it's
definitely you know if if your mom can't
accept you then you don't have a mom
there anymore you know what I mean and
it's very very toxic and it's like the
worst thing to tell to someone when
they're when they're needing support
beyond the superficial support of like
political activist like that only goes
so deep
right so it's it's wrong yeah
tell me a little more about that so in
that time of your life you're you're
starting to have these realizations or I
guess you had them very young but they
were becoming more concrete I suppose
and you were really in that SJW thing I
read something about how you had a list
of words on your refrigerator that was
it that you couldn't say or that people
who came to your house couldn't say I
didn't make it but I had a roommate that
I was probably fine with it but it was
like a whiteboard on the refrigerator a
list of words you couldn't say in the
house and it was like a stupid stuff it
was like terms like men's rights or I
was like I don't even remember it was
just all the things you would guess
right um so that was my life for a while
and were you when you were in it at that
time did you you so you really did feel
it like you thought it was wrong thing I
felt it it felt like finding like a new
purpose almost because at that time like
I said that was when the realization
that I was trans was really hitting hard
and so at that point you know you feel
you feel powerless you're at the
beginning you're like how do I make this
work you know how do I live my life in
the way that I want and you made a group
of people who tell you that you know
every problem you have isn't your
problem and everyone else is a problem
and then that's very intoxicating to
hear at that stage if you're that
confused or lost or whatever yeah so it
it's almost like they prey on weaklings
a lot they prey on the smaller groups so
disenfranchised groups and they suck
them up and become a bigger crate right
which in your case is particularly
interesting because now with someone
that has the views that you have and
will get to to some of those political
views and as you said you lean slight
right they're not a huge fan of yours
now no I have dealt with so much for my
youtube-channel day like something don't
even talk about yeah so much Jeff last
summer there was a huge run-in with
black lives matter and
a lot of the activists there obviously
saw my videos on black lives matter and
I was Doc's my address was posted people
were tweeting me about coming to my
house with guns all kinds of stuff what
you know it's crazy and it's online but
when it comes to that you have to take
it seriously so I was talks with the FBI
and a girl got arrested and my fans
I don't endorse it I do not endorse it
but my fans swatted the black lives
matter activists like sent you know
that's when you send I guess police to
someone's house and say they're gonna
kill themselves or something and they
cover guns so you know it's been really
crazy and I've lost a lot of friends
over it but it is worth it it YouTube
has changed my life I'm here I would
have never been here you know what I
mean so it's all worth it but there's
been so much just so much yeah does it
blow your mind how much of that online
world thing this you know the daxing the
swatting the fighting how much of that I
think in the last couple years
especially has sort of leaked into real
life where suddenly now you know if
someone knows where your address is they
can find or adjust any of that stuff
that that attitude has now leaked into
reality
yeah and it's a crazy attitude I mean a
lot of this stuff at the end of the day
I mean I see on Twitter sometimes people
getting docs you know ever seen like
viral tweets just going and someone's
getting Doc's because they said the
n-word or something and it's like okay
when you do that you're not only
affecting that person and putting them
at rest but it's like they might have
kids a wife a mother anyone in their
household you know what I mean something
it's crazy it's like the most insane
thing you can do to someone
yeah we've sort of lost civility right I
think the other things I mean yeah one
of the things I'm gonna try to do this
next year I think I try to do it in
general is bring some civility back to
some of this because we need it you know
you might not believe me but I'm trying
not to I really am I know you are
actually because you've been having
debates on your channel and you go
pretty deep with some people that you
obviously disagree with some people that
you've been in public fights with and
stuff like that and you're doing it in a
way that I think is civil yeah and the
way I do all my channel and stuff is
lately is I try to do debates and
especially just on the daily I mostly
only watch political content that I
disagree with honestly I don't really
turn on
fellow youtubers do the same thing as me
or you know news channels that kind of
mirror my views or whatever it's all
other stuff that's more interesting to
me because you want more about your own
views and someone else's views and
people don't stay caricatures yeah you
know people become people and idea has
become more tangible and something you
can actually argue against rather than
just being incendiary or whatever which
has been kind of my style in the past
but try anything's yeah alright so then
as someone who is now watching stuff
that you don't agree with so now that
means you're really watching a lot of
the diversity stuff probably long view
stuff and all that what's that I watch
the view watch the view that's it
I don't watch it anymore but that year
that one year where Elisabeth Hasselbeck
and Rosie were getting to fight
it was incredible telugu there and when
Elizabeth left I think it basically it
like it took like a like a hit to the
knee of the show but that I have no
problem with that show for the more I
haven't watched it lately yeah it's very
very liberal they had like and that's
why they needed Elizabeth right you
needed like the balance you can't just
how could the most conservative person
they have on there now is like a
libertarian and it's like it's fine but
like what everyone else is super far
left you have to have a balance yeah it
I don't like watching it because I
wouldn't about myself to do that you
know yeah so as someone that is watching
some of that stuff now and is now
debating some of these people what was
the moment for you that that political
thing switched not just the personal
part that was obvious you were going
through things but that moment that the
idea is how they relate to politics and
just sort of a worldview it was just
becoming an adult honestly it was
learning to take accountability for
myself and not relying on an ideology
that told me that I was powerless it was
yeah I'm just growing older which is
crazy when I see like you know 40 year
old you know activists which you know
fight for what you believe in but some
of these people have like the mindsets
of like teenagers it's crazy you know
just trying to push accountability on
other people yeah it's not not the best
way to be did any of your friends that
you were in at that time did they any of
them you know keep you around after that
or they apologized well it seemed like
just like that's it son but the ones
that stayed were the more you know
centered people or not like the crazy
activists those all dropped me like that
which is fine you know um I look at
where they are all in life and I don't
mind you did that very civilly it was a
gig I'm being nicer today it was very
civil that was very impressive
how old are you when you first started
doing the YouTube thing uh twenty to
twenty I'm almost 24 turning 24 in two
days geez well happy birthday in advance
but you're only barely two years that
you've been doing the YouTube thing I
mean that's like a life changer right
that's a transition of another sort
right going to the public person thing
absolutely YouTube has changed my life
opened up so many doors and never
thought would be opened I've met so many
amazing people through YouTube so I
believe in YouTube despite all the crazy
things happening right now like I
believe in YouTube I think it's an
amazing platform and I will stick with
it I might switch to other platforms as
well not switch but you know do stuff
other elsewhere yeah
but YouTube will always be at least I
hope my bread and butter you know all
right feel exactly the same way well
said all right so let's talk about such
as some of the issues and the stuff that
sometimes gets you in hot water and some
of the things that you as I said in the
beginning I consider you one of the
people that's a fearless defender of
free speech so first off so you agree
that trans is a mental disorder correct
yeah more specifically gender dysphoria
is mental disorder I mean that's just
recognized in the DSM so that's just
signing from the DSM 6 just for the for
the absolute layman will just do some
one-on-one stuff so gender dysphoria is
generators for is basically feeling a
strong disconnect with your gender and
gender roles that you're expected to
fill being that gender and it causes a
lot of you know distress and it's it's
very difficult it's like it's alleviated
a lot for me in the past year so but
when it was hitting me the hardest it's
so hard to do it with it's like
depression times 5 it's horrible yeah um
so it's a mental disorder which is fine
for me to admit because people have
disorder people have anxiety people have
depression people have you know whatever
so it's not this crazy inflammatory
thing for me to say at least I think but
a lot of other people feel differently
yeah
do you watch the show transparent by any
chance no no I don't so the one of the
interesting things I just watched
just in the last couple of months and
without getting into any plot stuff one
of the most interesting things to me is
that the father is transitioning and
really the story doesn't become about
the father it becomes about all the
people around him the family around him
and there's a moment where he becomes
friends with a trans woman who basically
is like you're gonna lose everyone
around you and that he hasn't yet in the
show I don't know which way they're
gonna go with it but that also must be a
part of the struggle after I it sounds
like it's been pretty okay for you but
for a lot of other trans people that
just other people just they can't even
if they want to except they just can't
get there for whatever reason yeah there
are people that can't get there it's
been in comparison to a lot of other
people relatively easy for me like I
have a huge family and 98 wasn't never
fine with it but but it is it is hard
you know like gender dysphoria it's all
fit you you have this like very toxic
view of yourself and it's very hard to
just exist and just go to the store and
just be yourself it's kind of hard to
explain to someone who would never
experience it you know what I mean but
it's basically feeling very
uncomfortable in your body like to the
extreme so to top that with like
familial like not being accepting it's
it's bad yeah do you think there's a
risk or any issue with LGBT QT that I
think in that like so for me as a gay
man I don't have any innate
understanding of what it's like to be
trans that a straight man wouldn't have
okay it's like sexuality and then
generate anything right so like just
inherently I don't somehow know
something more about you then if if I
happen to be straight or if there was a
straight guy sitting next to me do you
think that by clumping all these things
together there's some kind of risk there
like I think maybe perhaps I have a
little more empathy built into me
because I that was in the closet and
struggled and blah blah blah
yeah we have certain lies yeah like you
know somewhere it is but it is very
different I think in the beginning it
was necessary you know what I mean like
when there was less of an understanding
of what trans was it kind of was treated
like another you know these are the
queer people and this was that that was
their tribe yeah and so in the beginning
you know in the 60s during this journal
wall riots perhaps that was
beneficial now it is so different and
the politics are different and the place
that trans people are at and the place
that gay people and bisexual people and
lesbians rap is different I don't really
know what queer means you know I mean
like other words and a lot of letters
yeah I guess that's just like an
umbrella but then it's like Oh G B G is
already an umbrella acronym I don't know
yeah I guess um I don't think too much
about it as far as like with grouping
them in and why it might be bad yeah
it's not a big deal one of the things
I've seen you talk about is that you're
against having young kids transition as
early as seems to be happening more
often there was just a story this week
about what like a 14 year old boy who
transitioned who now wants to be in
transition or whatever whatever the
exact phrase is yeah and you've been
very outspoken about that absolutely
that's one of the I don't consider
myself as inside of like warrior fighter
but if there's a fight in my channel or
what I'm talking about
that's one of the things that I consider
one of the biggest fights because there
really are no other trans people
speaking out against it at least that
are like you know in the public eye or
whatever so I'm definitely against
children transitioning I think that it's
a horrible decision to let a child make
a life-changing decision and decide to
be sterile because that is a consequence
of transitioning so young kids and just
the drugs that they go on there's a lot
of problematic things go along with that
there's a show called I am jazz son I
think TLC or something and I'm it's
about a 16 year old trans girl and she
had been transitioning since she was
probably like 5 not medically medically
around like 11 or 12 so she's put on
puberty blockers which is what you go on
before hormones they basically she never
went through testosterone or male
puberty and because of that it's kind of
gnarly but her genitals like never
really developed and so she can't even
have the surgery to like become you know
a woman and have a vagina because she
was on Pirie blockers and puberty
blockers are hailed as like the most
important thing to go on yeah
wait can you explain that a little
further because I think back I think
that goes over a lot of people's head
it's like she actually needs to undergo
the proper
surgery at the end so to speak she
actually needs fully-formed
yeah female general yeah it's so gnarly
and it's like really graphic but the
amount of depth that you can have in the
vagina is directly related to how long
the penis is so if you are on puberty
blockers from the time you're 11 years
old you never develop you basically have
a micropenis no and you can never turn
it into a vagina it's just too small so
it's like those problems and the trans
activists for ibaka bio terms completely
gloss over it make it seem like
something that's not and I don't like
that
so I fight against that for sure yeah I
know of the show but I haven't been
watching it are they addressing that as
an issue like yeah they're going to like
consultations on the show and all these
surgeons are saying oh we can't do it
and there's only so many surgeons that
can do it there's like just like maybe a
dozen you asked to even do that so it's
like what do you know yeah it's so
interesting because it strikes me as
something that's so consistent with the
way you think of other things like just
cuz they're saying it just because
they're all saying oh let these kids on
it doesn't mean that even the facts if
you want to get to the end to truly
transition the facts don't line up with
what's making you feel good yes let kids
do whatever they want and okay all that
stuff but the actual medical reasons to
not do it from the amount that I
understand that you're explaining to me
Fars would supersede what your feelings
are absolutely another huge problem is
the activists always cite that you know
so many doctors are fine with it and
it's like okay but trans education in
medical school is actually very very new
like very new like it's it wasn't even
require doesn't show very recently if we
will to even learn about trans people
and transition in medical school and one
of the things that trans people walking
by and it's hard to even find like a
proper intro chronologist which is a
hormone specialist to even do the
transition so it's like you're citing
all these medical professionals when
half medical doesn't really know what
it's doing
people are just basically running into
the dark with this and that's what's
scary because kids lives are online you
know and I've never been the person
who's like a a child advocate fighting
for the kids kids are our future but you
know I mean that story alone that you
talked about was on my Twitter the other
day
the kid went on hormones at 12 decided
at 14 it was a mistake and it's like
cool like that kid just miss out on two
years of development who knows what's
gonna happen because of that yeah so
it's like playing with people's lives so
in a case like that so you have a 12
year old that is identifying as trans
what you would then want is for them to
do all the psychological work you would
want them to be fully accepted by their
family and friends and all of those
things but basically just wait on any
hormones or anything like that until is
it when puberty is done or do you think
it should be 18 like is there a number
associated with that for you where you
think okay well now is the moment or is
that individual well that's what's
difficult as well I mean bare minimum 18
for me I wouldn't really go higher than
that I think when you're Nate gene
you're an adult and you know for better
or worse you kind of have the ability to
mess up your life that's if that's the
case or make it amazingly better you
know my life I don't ever I don't ever
want to frame transition it's like
something that's like completely
negative like it's open my life up
entirely I would never I don't think you
do that at all
yeah yeah but it is something that's
also very serious and it changes the
entire course of your life so the idea
that you know kids are making that
decision is I think very problematic
yeah there's an interesting money piece
around this and you've talked a little
bit about that you don't want the
government paying for people's
transitioning first right yeah yeah yeah
for sure I mean I think that's something
I mean at the end of the day it is to
alleviate Jenner dysphoria which is a
disorder but it's all cosmetic and a way
to you know I mean like I just had
surgery I'm only like a month in a few
days out of surgery and you know
everyone's story is different but I
worked hard to save up for it and I paid
for it myself and it didn't go through
any like insurance or government or a
sugar daddy not so this was only paid
for yeah I wanted to do it that way
because I felt like I don't want to you
know live my life and look back and like
remember someone else footing the bill
you know what I mean it's my thing it's
my life and it just feels better that
way but again that's me yeah so this is
interesting then so as someone that
again you lean right so I don't know
what your feelings are on universal
health care per se but if we're
identifying gender dysphoria as a
disorder
someone was to have gender dysphoria how
could a health insurance company not
have to pay for it I'm going a little
insider baseball here with you yeah I
mean that's I mean that's completely
true I think it's about first of all we
have to learn how to actually diagnose
Jenner dysphoria properly because so
many people get diagnosed I don't really
have it they just don't so that needs to
be the first thing I'm meaning what and
what do they have they just have they're
just struggling with their sexuality or
a lot of identity issues yeah a lot of
the times um another interesting piece
of this is that trauma like emotional
trauma psychological trauma or physical
when you're younger if you're someone
who went through a rape or was beaten
can sometimes manifest that way I read a
story the other day of a kid who was
raised by a really abusive mother and
the mother used one of the ways that she
would abuse him when she would call him
by a female name and making more
addresses and stuff and as he got older
he had gender dysphoria what he thought
was gender dysphoria because he didn't
really know how to identify with his
gender because his abusive mother it was
like confusing the hell out of him and
he went and he transitioned and he did
everything like every surgery you could
do hormones everything and at the end
was like oh wow this isn't this isn't me
I'm not comfortable so there's a lot of
gray areas with this I feel like people
just don't pay attention to you yeah
which again is why it's scary that kids
are on the line for this yeah well it
just goes to how poorly we are about
debating really complex issues and I
would put this at sort of this deals
with so much it's sort of an existential
level and a biological level and
everything else yeah this should be
something that really we should be
debating from the most educated place
and I think we do a horrible job of that
well you a horrible job I don't even do
the best job it's hard you know there's
like I said there's so many gray areas
and there's so many like for instance
there is the American College of
pediatrics I believe it's called
a lot of people cite them as a good
source they're not like they're not
actually pediatricians they have the
name and a lot of people cite like a lot
of really anti-trans stuff from them
well it's not a real source and people
really go hard with that so it's like
there's just so much it's just a mess
yeah that's why I said I think it's
almost better like people didn't really
know what
because there was the few doctors that
can do it and it's like if you needed it
you know 0.1 returned the population
it's fine
but now it's like everyone's involved
everyone has an opinion and just makes
it harder yeah it's such a symptom of
what's going on in a bigger way in
society of just everyone having an
opinion about everything now I know
we're all for the free speech thing so
these people should be allowed to say
whatever they want of course and
encourage but just this this endless
opinion machine on things that people
don't know about I think a great example
of that is when Trump made this
Proclamation about the the trans ban and
you were the first person I quickly
jumped on Twitter all right who can I
try to make some sense of this and from
what was your basic take on it I think
you had a similar opinion at first I
don't know if you change your as I kind
of shifted mine but initially I was like
why you know I mean like it doesn't make
sense but I picked the fight yeah why I
picked the fight why is it important um
I think there's like a very small amount
of trans people in the army that's never
really been an issue but it also took me
like I'm just some prissy training from
California you know what I mean like I
don't know about how the military like
it took me kind of looking at like oh
wow there's actually like basically if
you stub your toe the wrong way you
can't show the military so of course if
you have like genders for it's something
that's like that debilitating like maybe
you shouldn't be at least on the front
lines for me I felt like banning trans
people from every you know position in
the military was kind of little overkill
but I can understand the frontlines
thing for sure yeah did you change open
you know what do you well I tried to I
tried and you know you sometimes fail on
Twitter but I tried to tweet out a few
different thoughts that I was having
because I wasn't feeling like I fully
understand this and sort of what you're
saying it's like I'm not in the military
also so for me to pretend that I know
everything about protocol and what it's
like to be on the battlefield or in a
you know in a housing unit with a bunch
of soldiers and all of those things so I
tried to look at what some military
people were saying people like you a few
other people that I generally respect I
mean my feeling is that if you have
transitioned so first off there's the
argument about the money right so I
don't think the government should I
don't think the military should have to
pay for your transition that's just what
I feel that's my more libertarian side
coming out but that's okay so all right
so we got one there the other part
though is that if you
have passed every psychological test if
you've transitioned and now you've
passed every psychological test that
they would apply to everyone else well I
do believe in equal opportunity so at
that point I would argue it's probably
irrelevant whether it's combat or
anything else but I also tweeted a list
of things that there was a guy who's a
military guy did you see that who
tweeted out like a 20 string tweet about
the pressures of the family on the
battlefield and he was making it clear
that he's not against trans people in
any way he was just saying if there's an
extra element of psychological issues
there that it could complicate things I
just thought it was an interesting take
him and of course I got a lot of hate
for even sharing it yeah I saw that yeah
I said just read this with an open mind
that's all I was really saying so but
yeah see the point is that it goes to
one of those things where it's like man
this is complicated [ __ ] it is it is one
of the main concerns I had with the
whole situation was just um finding out
and making sure that the trans people
who already were in the military didn't
lose any link VA benefits afterwards
because that's that's really property to
like serve your life and then leave and
it's just like you're dishonorably
discharged and no benefits that that's
crappy to me but I'm not losing sleep
over like not being able to be drafted
now so that's great I'm cool with that
right there you go that's pretty guys by
the way we are gonna do patreon and
super chat questions after about an hour
with Blair we're gonna jump in let you
guys do that so you can put questions on
patreon and on super chat right now
let's talk a little bit let's move away
some from trans stuff have we have we
done it for now you think did you miss
anything you feel like we got it okay
okay good
some of the other political stuff so you
describe yourself as leaning right and
you obviously have a libertarian piece
of you what what else does that mean if
you say I lean right right well you know
I hold some leftist juice as well you
know what I mean like I think you and I
both agree on the traditional you know
free speech I think that still defined
is like a leftist thing I was really I
was saying the other day you know maybe
like we aren't all moving right maybe
everything's just moving left I think
that's actually the case that everything
else is moving left or that not so far
all kind of yeah the world does move
laughs you haven't moved right maybe
that's the case but when it comes to
fiscal responsibility when it comes to
national security when it comes to you
know just a lot of things and so I
definitely say lean right but I also
don't fight for any team you know what I
mean I'm not rooting for any team I
speak for myself I analyze each issue in
situation and come out with what I think
going on does that put you in an
interesting position because it kind of
opens you up from hate for everybody
like you know I'll see people like
Rubens a secret Republican conservative
hablan I'm like if that if that's true
or though he's far right he's all right
all this crazy [ __ ] it's like if that's
true well then I guess those guys are
okay with gay marriage they're okay with
someone who's pro-choice there's someone
who's Pro legalization of marijuana who
doesn't want a nation billed for
euthanasia I mean a good Julie you know
forced her own public education blah
blah blah yeah yeah it definitely does
because first of all you can never
please everyone and we live in such a
such a divisive time and look at Tommy
Lehren like she took one step outside of
you know her team with via what was it
the abortion comments on the view and
like she was everything she's doing good
now which is great yeah but she lost
everything so we live in a time where
people are all playing by the book and
fighting for teams which really has
never been my side which is fine because
I'm on YouTube and it's independent it's
fine good I mean I don't have any one's
gonna fire me right you want a piece of
wood that we could just put maybe yeah
describe you that way that would be
better you could just keep it in your
pocket and just kind of let me do that
you know I actually don't know your
feelings on abortion did you agree with
the premise of what Tommy was saying um
I go so back and forth on abortion
there's a small part I mean it's like oh
my god I'm trans and I have to deal with
that I almost don't want to talk about
it but I do you know obviously have
views on it I will not accept that as an
answer yeah I know I know I know
I'm definitely pro-life with the
exception just as a general rule
pro-life with the exception of incest
and rape kind of the basic thing you
know what I mean I think that if you
don't have to have an abortion you
shouldn't but at the same time it's not
libertarian to me I'm not trying to tell
someone what they should do with their
bodies just for me a moral decision
would be if I could get pregnant would
be that I would be pro-life unless I got
raped or had an incest situation
yeah it's one of those things that's so
complicated and that's why when I see
these idiots screaming at each other
it's like no one hates women and no one
babies it's like one is trying to
protect life in that sense and one is
trying to protect the woman so for
someone like you that has that
libertarian bent though if you were
going to and we're totally just
spitballing this obviously we didn't
discuss any of this stuff that we were
gonna talk that if you were as a
pro-life person what would you do then
if a woman let's say a 16 year old girl
gets pregnant it's an accident whatever
she has no support or anything do you
think the government has any role if the
government's not going to allow her to
have an abortion do you think the
government has any role then in well in
helping that child helping her etc I
think so if we're gonna keep it illegal
then there needs to be some type of
recourse I mean you can't just have
dumpster be him he's I mean sounds so
horrible but that's kind of the reality
of what happens is like if someone can't
take care of a baby you literally cannot
and has no family
those kids end up in dumpsters those
kids end up dying those kids end up you
know with malnutrition so that is a
thing yeah pressure yeah I mean I'm with
you on that basically like yes in most
cases I would like either their
community or their church or mosque or
whatever it is to help take care of them
but this is one of the places where I
think if the government's gonna say no
you can't do this then it's some way the
government is sort of responsible so
it's one of those places where all of us
have these sort of political ideas and
yet the rubber meets the road and then
you gotta kind of really believe and I'm
such a like individualist that whenever
I hear a question like what you think of
abortion I automatically put it back to
myself what I would do so obviously what
I would do is you know not have an
abortion but it's a wide world out there
a lot of different situations so I'd
agree there should be recourse if it's
illegal
yeah I like that you just said the
phrase individualist because I think and
I mentioned the LGBTQ thing before that
because I'm a little older than you that
when even though when I was closeted for
a long time and I never really felt that
I was part of the gay community whatever
that is I never I always liked
basketball and if I'm a horrible dancer
like I just never really felt in it like
that yeah you like basketball oh no no I
never fit in LGBT are you good answer ah
kind of I dance we don't have like a
husband which these days is particularly
weird
used to be like kind of corny and fun
now I dance like the greatest serial
rape or of all time it's okay we have to
go out yeah but that the idea that the
LGBTQ community whatever you want to
call that has lost some of the
individualism is actually very sad to me
that I used to live in West Hollywood
which is basically the gayest place on
earth there a rainbow cross truly I mean
it is the gayest place and that the
community is sort of succumbed to
groupthink even when when gay people
weren't treated equally there was a very
cool rebel streak I think Milo actually
makes this point really well there was
like this sort of subversive like oh
yeah and I think they've traded it I
suppose for equality which of course is
very important under the law but it's
their loses a little you see that too
even with the trans community community
I hate the word community - I know but I
mean it is a community really I mean
even if I'm not a part of it as a
community I've never felt a part of it
I've always I mean there's I've always
felt there's a lot of problems
particularly I can't really speak to the
gay community I've had a lot of gay
friends but I've never been like super
involved in that mmm secretary but when
it comes to trans people there's so many
problems with with that community so
much sex work so much disconnect from
family no family values not community
really and so that's always been a
problem for me I've never really been
able to relate to other trans people
every once in a blue moon then I meet
one that's like down-to-earth and normal
and fine not that I'm like the most
normal person but I've never felt at
home in that community or the LGBT
community I've been to million gay and
trans and lesbian functions always [ __ ]
the black sheep not not in a negative
way like all these people are bad or
Never but it just never been my tribe
yeah I mean we should do some sort of
like we should do like a get-together
for like the black sheep tears that's a
that's a party that I could actually
probably have fun that probably probably
it's always been kind of a thing for me
and for a long time I was like upset by
it like that I couldn't relate to them
and I thought something's wrong with me
but then I look at the state and it
sounds like I'm like just trash-talking
the trans community but I guess I kind
of am I look at the state of where that
community is and it's like why would I
want to fit in
I mean I don't have anything against X
when I crochet but it's very depressing
to be around a bunch of people who feel
like the only thing they can do in life
is sex work mm-hmm
that's like their only course of action
because the truth is it really isn't I
mean those issues and there's severe
unemployment problem in the trans
community but we're not at this place of
like trans people can only have sex for
money yeah and I just don't like being
around that honestly yeah I sound like
an uptight question but I know it's late
II I don't it's just not fun to be
around honestly a different lifestyle
all right let's take a big loop big jump
big jump Islam you talk about Islam that
makes a certain amount of people not
like you yeah when I've watched your
videos on Islam I think you do a pretty
good job of making a distinction between
a set of ideas and a group of people and
that we shouldn't be prejudiced towards
people but we're allowed to criticize
ideas yeah that doesn't get through to a
lot of people no it doesn't it doesn't
um so obviously as a trans person that I
have a huge problem with Islam I would
have a huge problem living in any
Islamic country um is there one you
could openly the way you would want to
live that you know of there's about 40
or so I don't think being trans because
um even dubai like that's supposed to be
like the the liberal haven of the Muslim
world and even there there's on a lot of
problems there's a youtuber named Gigi
gorgeous who like was stopped at the
airport couldn't answer the country it
was like detained so it's like well you
can't go to Dubai like where can you go
certainly not Saudi Arabia wasn't there
even a straight a heterosexual couple
that was kissing on the beach in Dubai
and got arrested I mean yeah so it's not
quite yeah it's not there are other
problems too yeah clearly
yeah clearly the liberal haven yeah
clearly so um but even more so than like
religion I I focus on culture and I
would never want that culture should
become something that's super prominent
here
because that wouldn't be in my best
interest you know what I mean or
anyone's best interest woman's best
interest men's best interest a lot of
people a lot of people talk about women
in the Muslim world as you know as
victims which they are you know I get a
lot of just insane messages from women
and LGBT people in the Middle East but I
also get a lot from men
who feel like they're trapped as well
everyone's in a very strict role there
yeah so it would be in no one's best
interest for that to be here yeah so
what makes the left go so defensive on
Islam and so offensive on Christianity
because they're brown I think they're
brown they think they think there are
plenty of white Muslims there's plenty
of went around Christians absolutely so
that's a huge misconception on the left
where I think they fight so hard because
which is why they call you know people
who voiced concerns about Islam racist
because they associate that with brown
people and apparently if you're brown
you have to have all these you know
twenty year old white saviors jumping
here your rescue if you could only have
more purple haired girls at colleges
defending you then everything would be
okay right right it becomes around
honestly it's really that simple I think
which then as I've said many times is
the actual definition of prejudice
obviously we're prejudging people based
on their color absolutely because you
think of a you know when it comes to
Christianity like the slightest problem
with Christianity which there are some
but not really lemony anymore um they'll
jump on that like that like the the gay
cake situations all the time that pop up
sometimes you know that'll be like the
end of the world
yeah where were you on the gay cake
thing by the way just there's a segue um
I didn't care
Carrie what's the stupidest thing in the
world whenever that pops up it's like
but what I didn't like is that um be
small shop owner just get their lives
ruined over it and it's just like media
attention to the extreme and like their
shops get shut down and they lose their
livelihood
that's horrible um but another one of
those like petty disputes I just I can't
care about that too much yeah yeah I'm
guessing you were probably basically
with me on that which B would be that I
don't want the government telling a
private company absolutely a specific
service I wouldn't demand that the
government tell a Jewish painter to be
forced to paint Holocaust imagery if
someone commissioned them to do it so
it's sort of a sucky thing it kind of
sucks like feel don't feel right but
yeah it doesn't feel right it's not to
say that that's like the kind of the
Christian thing to do to turn someone
away but what people don't talk about is
a lot of these activists go to places
like
they go to Christian bakeries because
they want to start something they want
to media attention they want to you want
something to fight for
um that's messed up yeah all right so
here's we're gonna do guys where you are
gonna take questions with Blair in about
five minutes again we're doing it on
super chat we're doing it on patreon
there are roughly four jillion of them
already can you do all four Jillian up I
can do all four or for Jillian that's
all right but but so sort of one last
thing that I want to make sure we get to
in case we don't get it two questions so
you did just as you said just about a
month ago you underwent several other
surgeries which you were very open about
there's a video on your channel where
you were you holding the camera and that
one yeah I was so you're holding the
camera and you know you've got the
bandages all over and you're talking
about so can you just describe a couple
of the things that that you underwent
done I got me arrested I got my forehead
basically reconstructed biological males
have a ridge on their forehead they also
have a higher hairline it is more space
in between the eyebrows and the eyeballs
so I got all that changed my eyebrows
lifted my brow bone shaved my hairline
lowered and I also got a rhinoplasty so
just those three things and from there
like I'm done with my transition which
is like an amazing feeling to have a
done at 23 it was probably not even
probably it was the most intense thing
I've ever been through the most pain I
have 40 staples that went all along my
head like to the back of my ears nose
job was fine nose job didn't hurt that
much the best heard a lot of elephants
out on my chest so I'm just glad to be
mostly healed I'm still a little swollen
honestly I was probably advised to like
not get back to like being on camera yet
but I had you I had you yeah I mean it's
incredible to me after watching that
video and I was looking at it going wait
a minute wait a minute this is only a
month ago and then I were gonna be here
today and it's you know seen pictures of
you since then and all that I was like
holy cow I mean the human body is
actually an amazing thing it could heal
lutely I mean I was literally like
sliced open like the way they do it you
wanna get really graphic let's go the
way they do it is so they make an
incision all along like I said to the
back of your ear as they peel your face
down and then they like it's almost like
a medieval feeling they saw the bone
down so I was like Leatherface how
afraid were you either that something
could could
actually go wrong which I'm sure does
happen sometimes or that you know you
could look at now you're in LA I mean
you're gonna walk around and see all
these women all the time and plenty of
men now to actually with you know
plastic surgery gone wrong that are
having far less done than what you just
did
how worried were you when you just when
you finally took that last gasp of the
gas or whatever when they put you under
I wasn't worried honestly because like
I'm not dumb and like I did my research
and I made sure I was going to you was a
great doctor um so I had faith in him
but of course you go through like the
the freakout like the night before like
I've walked and I was like crying I was
like so scared because it was my first
surgery but it was also something that
was really important to me so I got
through it and it improved my life
exponentially exponentially like I feel
just so much better about myself and
like everything is just kind of I can
breathe it's great yeah it's incredible
I mean it's like it's really it's like
the aura of what you're talking about
it's coming through for sure
so you said those are the last series
now you did not have bottom surgery
correct yeah and and what's your
reasoning on that and a lot of reasons
why I haven't got them done if I could
have like a fully functioning like
perfect vagina out the womb great I
would do that but when it comes to that
surgery it's so much money it's tens of
thousands of dollars it's a lot of risk
like it's a very risky surgery it's the
best it's ever been it's risky in terms
of actual life or is it just in terms
not like dad but like complications you
mean like you can lose the ability to
orgasm which I mean that's like that's
like really important in life is orgasm
you're down with the orgasm and also the
recovery time is extreme it's like a
year of recovery and it's really intense
recovery it's like the worst like way
worse than what I did um and I don't
have the downtime that we like just like
in my room for a year can't like it's
just it's it's not for me so I'm
comfortable with how I am now and I'm
just done yeah all right I think we're
gonna move on to some audience questions
Oh God
how'd I do I think I did all right great
idea you did great too you want even
pause there should we oh you know we are
gonna pause for 30 seconds I'm gonna
refill your water all right guys one
more time
questions on patreon questions on super
chat so we'll load them up right now
give us one minute for a little water
and check on the dog and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys we're back with Blaire
white how's your leg it's good it was so
dead horrible alright we had to get up
we did a little stretching okay we're
good to go alright there's a zillion
things here so let's just jump right in
from patreon how difficult has the trans
community community been with her given
many of her views that run counter to
the general position they hold we talked
about this a little bit but have you
gotten like any particularly like really
hateful stuff from trans people because
you talk about the things if you just
search up like we're white trans on
YouTube like there's a million videos
from trans people who are just like
trashing me which is fine um ton of
threats ton of like if you show up at
this event we're gonna do this and it's
crazy but a lot of the trans activists
that I'm actually transferred as
activists who fight for trans people cuz
that's like their fight yeah um they're
the worst though they're the worst
that's interesting because Bret
Weinstein at Evergreen State was telling
me that sort of same thing he never
feared violence from any of the black
students but he feared violence from the
white students because they were the
ones that had to really prove how Pro
black or whatever that they really were
we really kind of kind of fascinating
super chat Dave your beard is looking
good hashtag no shave Dave okay thank
you
we met do you have a alright there I
think it's Diane do you have a favorite
subscriber and would you ever consider
doing a collab video with them favorite
subscriber a favorite subscriber I think
someone's trying to hint something to
you the braid probably just all my
patrons of words because obviously they
go the hardest you know and they're the
greatest that would be cool to do a
video like with all the patreon
supporters yeah how important is the
patreon thing to you I don't even mean
just financially but just the fact that
people are like I'm voluntarily doing
this like if if half of them dropped you
probably still figure out a way to make
videos you know yeah and yet they're
voluntarily saying take this and
hopefully these ideas get out there
anything absolutely
I love that I mean the fact that another
person would say this content and this
person is worth this even if it's a
dollar you know it's it's it's very
flattering
absolutely all right patreon what is
your opinion on special rights and
benefits for specific groups of people
for example my
already's have a fern of affirmative
action married people get a financial
benefit people with kids get tax breaks
etc I'm looking forward to the tax
breaks I think it Mary so let's make me
keep that affirmative action I feel like
there was a time and place for that
which is now gone especially for women
and then as far as like if we can relate
it to like the trans thing a lot of the
activists fight for special employment
rights like not being able to use the
wrong pronoun in the workplace which
actually makes the trans person who's
being employed a huge liability because
then like who wants to hire someone
who's like a financial it's already bad
enough for the trans community as far as
unemployment and they make it worse yeah
are you pretty much in lockstep with
Jordan Peterson on the the pronoun stuff
like right now he's not against train
I've never heard him say one anti last
person thing just don't tell me what I
have to say and certainly don't make it
a law absolutely
he's tweeted me and been very kind to me
he's not a hater of trans people he just
doesn't want to be told what to say
which is like the bare minimum in life
like tell me what I said right super
chat are gay traps also straight oh my
god that's like you explained
mathematical yes really are gay trap
still straight yeah what do they mean by
trap so this is like a newer phrasing
okay so trap is like it's like 4chan
lingo for originated I believe it's like
boys are dressed up as girls and don't
tell the person they're sleeping with
they're not trans or like traps or just
like you've probably seen the trip
around Hollywood yeah they're not trans
or not making changes like that but
they're just like they're trapping
people it's just like super immoral it
just like horrible so traps are gay
because they're they're just gave ways
like dressing up their girls and
tricking guys right not forget make
sense to me simple man super chat combat
vet here I have seen war and can say
with confidence that it is not the place
for a group with a 40 percent lifetime
suicide rate why create even more
suicidal vets thanks for your candor not
see that's an interesting way of looking
at it that there are so many vets
already with suicide problems I don't
know that I right link that together
right I mean I don't think there's any
die
to see if that like compounds or
something or even like put together you
know any but again I much prefer to hear
from people like that then to stay here
as like like I said a pretty trainee
from California are talking about like
Oh military is that like I just I take
that with more than a grain of salt for
sure yeah that's interesting
you know you say the word [ __ ] and I
know that a certain amount of people are
you know freakin probable while watching
is but you're just trying to own the
word right I mean I don't or even
anything I know that you're even I think
it's like you word I think it's a funny
word I don't mind it fair enough
we touch on this a little bit but maybe
you have like a pretty coder saying what
does your family think of your videos so
we talk about the family you so yeah
that's it that's a good question I've it
is um they'll talk about it much like I
said my family it's bacon most of them
are very liberal so it's probably just
talk they don't want to talk about but
one thing you learn about when you start
YouTube where you start doing videos or
public stuff is that everyone you know
and you've ever known like everyone you
know what I mean
you kind of don't expect that but
everyone watches it um I've never had
any like negative backlash from I
actually know that's a lie I had a
cousin who blocked me on Facebook like
she wants to go this she was saying um
she doesn't want anyone to think she's a
fan of me because she hates my videos or
something I was like well that's so mean
well but um other than that it's been
fine in a way there's something kind of
good about that because it's like she
probably was okay with you being trans
who doesn't like your political ideas so
although that sucks and I talk about why
that's wrong all the time blocking
people over that but there's something
kind of funny in that it's like I'm okay
with you as a human can't take your
political views whatever super chata
long live freedom of speech you okay I
think we both agree on that
this is good because we touch on this
right at the end from super chat what
kind of psychological benefits does the
appearance change and surgeries have on
you and are there any detriments how do
you decide you were stable enough so you
made it pretty clear like that you
really feel like yourself now you feel
good about what just happened and all
that I am but are were there any
detrimental side effects to that or
anything like afterwards like changing
how you look was there detrimental side
yeah I think yeah like any level of
regret or
no I was hit pretty hard with like a
post-surgery depression which is very
normal matter what you're getting done
so there was like a few days where I was
like oh my god what did I do like this
is so painful I don't know if I'm gonna
like how it looks at the end but it's
completely changed my life now in only
positive ways like I feel more confident
I've like I'm okay with like the camera
hitting me from whatever angle because I
know that like I'm fine now in my face
so you have no idea how many angles
we're working but it's been great yeah
we did touch on this one a little bit
before but I don't know if we got an
exact number what do you think is the
minimum appropriate age to talk to kids
about gender dysphoria our parents
justified in sheltering their kids from
these topics uh-huh I sent her to
completely justified I am when I have
appears I'm definitely not going to be
talking about all this stuff with that
my children obviously the trans thing is
gonna come up because I'll be able to
Google me or whatever but I don't see
any reason why anything beyond teaching
kids to be kind to people regardless of
who they're interacting with I don't see
why you should go past that I think when
they get a little older and you know
they hit puberty and start learning that
you know the boys in their class
sometimes are going for the other boys
whatever and then it's like appropriate
but when it's like a little kids don't
confuse them I'm curious have you ever
been approached by any of the LGBTQ
organizations or glad or human rights or
any of the so not which so I want people
to really understand that because I was
always ignored by all them when I was
doing my thing too because I was even
though I wasn't fully where I am now and
why I wasn't there
yeah and I was always ignored by them
and I'm ignored by them now which I
don't even care about but I but I think
people should really understand that
that you because you're an individual
who thinks what you think they will
never this group from this sort of
umbrella group that controls a lot of
the gay fun out there you'll never see
me at an HRC red-carpet
at GLAAD red card never you know I don't
mind it even even with YouTube like I
see YouTube promoting trans youtubers
who it's not about size but are much
smaller like a thousand subscribers
simply because they're maintaining the
narrative they want them to maintain the
videos aren't even that great
and again not that my videos are amazing
but no but you but your videos are great
and all right and your audience loves
them and you get numbers and all that so
that does show you how this diversity
memo that we've all been talking about
with this James the more thing at Google
a lot how that has seeped into all of
these companies
why can't you to promote one of your
videos if they're doing something about
trans people right and I guess I can
understand certain videos like you don't
have to promote the ones where it's like
you know me with blood on my face
talking about how trainings get beat up
for tricking man or something you know I
mean like that one but like normal ones
like my transition video why not
everyone else does it lets trans but I'm
not losing sleep over it I'm doing my
own thing yeah all right guys reminder
we are taking questions on super chat
right here on YouTube or also taking
questions on patreon and here we go do
you feel that having so many different
labels in the transgender community
helps or hinders the idea of gender
diversity for example does it open the
doors to free sexuality or does it
create more barriers what do they mean
by so many different labels in the
transgender community are there are
there labels that I may be missing
within the community itself I think so
because they they do like the non-binary
thing and like the a gender thing and
there's just a lot of different terms
floating around and it creates barriers
for sure I mean that's just kind of how
the human mind works we categorize
people and we find our tribe and you
start splitting the tribe even smaller
it's like then it's just a bunch of
people who are in their own little
bubbles you know it does create division
it doesn't bring people together no do
you think it also just causes exhaustion
I talked a little bit about this with
Laci green that when you get something
to the point where you have to label
every little person's feelings about
every little thing only that I think the
average person is just like [ __ ] this
like I don't need to I'm not even gonna
talk about this right boy right like you
NIH's audience like we're very involved
in all these conversations but when it
comes to real people like you can't just
walk to 7-eleven start talking about
non-binary and like it doesn't compute
it's not real life that goes back to me
saying I don't appreciate being like
expected to suspend my belief of how the
real world works so it's like it's
almost tiring talking about it that
being said you are pretty upset about
the amounts of non-binary cashiers at
7-eleven these days right right there's
so many it's just so many
and it really it's just sickening
Supercat hi Blair what are your thoughts
regarding passing as it relates to
politics around trans issues also
apparently jazz is getting surgery I
read so that news to you well good for
her she found a surgeon I didn't know
that there was like a struggle which is
crazy
um what about that's interesting the
passing as it relates to politics I
guess the way you could relate that is
that Caitlyn Jenner because she
obviously had great surgeons and you
know some people it's probably just a
little more it's just about I didn't
want it so that their features at the
beginning may be a little more easy to
transition with or whatever it is that
if she had come out on the other side
looking very different or not passing
that perhaps she wouldn't have been as
accepted as she was probably yeah I mean
I mean that's another way that human
mind works like we like to look at
people and especially when it comes to a
gender we like to look at people and
like know what they are because
identifying gender is subconscious you
look at someone you don't think it's not
like a thought is that a man or woman
it's like you see features and your mind
automatically it triggers and you know
what they are automatically so it is
more digestible to have someone who just
you know what they are or even if you
know they're trans they look enough to
it like they're normal-looking you know
what I mean so it is hard and not
everyone has access to surgeries or
whatever so you can be aware that it
helps but I don't think it's like that
doctor mental either yeah I don't know
I'm thrown in a bonus one for me because
I'm here when it comes to just the
general hate and just okay so these
people go after you and yes a certain
amount of people are gonna go after you
now cuz you're popular and all of those
things you know I know a lot of people
say oh I don't care about any of that I
don't read any of that but I'd really
sense something and you like I really
sense that you don't care at all
I don't care because again it's not real
life it's like I have my boyfriend back
in the green room I have my mom I can go
off in you talk to her I have my family
I have roof over my head what why would
I care why would I care you know as long
as you're not putting your hands on me
or like being crazy in public which is
really not happen not much to me a few
times that I'm fine yeah I think we all
need a little more of that in our lives
probably probably me included regarding
puberty blockers this is from patreon
regarding puberty blockers and/or
hormone treatment for children consent
becomes an issue don't you think it
makes more sense to wait until they have
better executive functions relevant for
consent as measured by objective
criteria such as prefrontal cortex
development rate which would be white
gray matter of ratio of change similar
to those we already consider capable of
consent this would be about fourteen to
sixteen years old on average if I
remember well so I like the fact that
that was kind of technical but basically
saying that there's a you need their own
brains to be analyst enough yeah yeah I
mean just think about yourself the
twelve you you think you really could
have made a decision that impacts the
rest of your life you just can't I think
of myself at thirty-five I was an idiot
right right till you get the thirty-five
right you have no idea not one in four
but yeah I totally agree that they can't
even properly consent they can't consent
to sex legally they can't consent to
drinking they can't consent to driving
you're looking to consent just changing
their sex it's crazy
hmm it's a really interesting thing are
there any other trans youtubers who
think the way you do that's interesting
because there's definitely plenty that
go after you I see enough about that are
there some that are on the on the Blair
train um yeah
one of the most interesting things about
my channel is that I I don't want to
sound conceited but because of my
channel there's been other trans people
it'll come out and like been like
Blair's the reason why I feel like I can
say this that ain't conceited that's
jealous okay that's just honest so
that's been really great for me just to
see everyone's tomorrow video will pop
up from a trans person saying so I've
thought this all my life but I didn't
want to say it but I saw Blair talking
about it and now I can and I think
that's great you know what I mean I
think the more freedom to say what you
want the better yeah sure so there's a
few not a lot though obviously I'm the
minority in this community so and there
but there are there for sure I mentioned
that I had been at my brother-in-law's
farm in Seattle and it's sort of a
communal farm and he lives with the
trans girl who was a gun advocate and
she was painting her she was painting
her gun locker pink while we were there
she you know hunts and does all kinds of
other stuff and it was during that whole
thing about the the army and oh and that
was one of the things I tweeted that day
which was like I would much rather have
this girl defending me than me - she
knows a lot more about
and could probably live off the grid a
lot longer than I could so it's like
right what I have it's kind of like a
misconception people think
transgenderism is political it's really
not it's definitely outside the
political realm people just politicize
it you know what I mean so that's why
I've always said you could mean like a
gun-toting [ __ ] in Alabama or a green
hair a feminist [ __ ] in San Francisco
there is a lot of intellectual diversity
it's not as much as there should be
because a lot of people do feel pressure
to align more with the green hair in San
Francisco [ __ ] but right it's a matter
we shouldn't judge as individuals and
not as collectives almost like that boy
it really makes you think all right guys
we are still on patreon at super track
here we go
for both of you which community has been
the most hostile least accepting of you
as a bi libertarian man my Christian
conservative friends have been very
accepting the gay community the least
you want me to feel that one first
yeah so I find lately especially I'm
finding that the Christian conservative
Christian community has been absurdly
open I think they've sort of gotten not
to say there aren't some people using
scripture in a bigoted way but even when
I was on vacation I met these Christian
conservatives that could not have cared
less and they wanted to know if I'm a
good person and all that I think right
now ever all the things that I believe
in I get more flak action but I get way
more from just the so-called tolerant
and laughs then on the right people
don't I get invited to all these I'm
speaking tonight at a libertarian thing
at at a college outside of LA and it's
like Claremont McKenna and it's like
these are supposed to be scary
right-wingers and their enemy yeah and
they're inviting the gay married
pro-choice Pro weed guy to come talk to
them so who is intolerant what about for
you absolutely and I completely relate
to that I didn't expect to be that way
though it took me making my youtube
channel to kind of understand that like
it is kind of a new thing but it's there
that people care more about ideas and
people you know what I mean or than
identities so a lot of my hate almost
98% of my hate comes from people who
fight for trans rights which is so crazy
to me yeah god that's not I mean I would
say 98% problem that's probably the
right number for me it's like I never
get hate mail from people on the right
back
approach don't they go we disagree with
you or I've had people sitting in this
very chair in my own home who told me
they weren't for gay marriage but I was
okay with the conversation yeah yeah
real life conversations wrong is so
different you know they're better there
you go
would you be interested in talking to
ben shapiro about transgenderism i would
love to you actually was doing a
livestream a week ago and i was saying
how i would love to do a video with ben
shapiro just talking about it not
necessarily a heated debate or whatever
but i'm just going over it'd be so
interesting cuz we have some reviews but
also radically different views when it
comes to it you know what why don't I
talk to bed and we'll see if we can do
it right here yeah I I think you know
you know he Ben's a good guy and even if
you guys won't make peace on that
specific thing I think there's a lot
more that you agree with and I know that
project you'd use that as a jumping off
point all right do you think the gender
dysphoria is something that one is born
with or do you think it's a product and
or rejection of one's environment I
think it can be both um I think back in
my life and I remember being 4 or 5
years old feeling it so to me that feels
like wow maybe I really was born with
something you know different in my brain
and that's why I had it happening but
like I said there is events like trauma
that can cause what feels like genders
for you or even gender dysphoria
so it could be both for sure all right
super chat we got a but we got about 12
minutes left guys if you want to jump in
on super chat or on patreon with LASIK
eye surgery not being covered by most
health insurance companies it's rated
the same as plastic surgery why is trans
being pushed when there are others that
benefit physical health that's that's an
interesting question I mean I couldn't
say I guess when it comes to being trans
there's like the suicide aspect and when
it comes to talking bad eyesight is just
having bad I say I want Lisa to by the
way horrible eyes I knew you weren't
done with your surgeries I am legally
blind you don't know that I'm legally
blind I have contacts in right now but
lookout them I wouldn't be able to see
you really yeah I had it's very passable
attacks thank very passable oh this is
really interesting from patreon thoughts
on TSA body scanners as it relates to
trans men and well I have so much as I
yeah yeah okay
so I've been flying a lot this summer I
have a boyfriend out here something
going back and forth from where I live
to LA where he lives and every single
time I have ever flown in my life since
being trans since transitioning I've
been the scanner pops up my body and I
have to get patted down every single
time I've never not had that happen and
it definitely is like super invasive and
it's like because what happens is when
you go up to TSA the agent has to select
male or female so when I'm walking
through they select female but then on
the scanner an anomaly pops up in the
crotch area which is you know what I
mean right
so every time happy I call an anomaly
so it's invasive it's really frustrating
I understand that TSA is there to keep
everyone safe but it's like the worst
thing in the world because sometimes
they're like rude about it and you're
treated like you're a terrorist
yeah that's like come on yeah I'm
walking in like section shield on wanted
terrorists right I mean everyone hates
TSA so much yeah and so much of it is
such the theater of the absurd that
adding this into it I tell me imagine
last time it was the worst last time I
flew they took me to the back and
everything and they're like asking me
questions I was like are you kidding me
I literally was told I have a penis
yeah we're just helping them I have a
peanut hello it's frustrating but Sir
day is what it is I suppose patreon even
if sex is genetically defined don't you
think it makes more sense for sexual
orientation to be based on our pattern
of attraction based on what triggers it
that is since we have no gene scanning
vision the secondary sexual
characteristics of a person an overall
masculinity femininity femininity
instead of sex something there might
have went over my head is the same
that's kind of a confusing question yeah
all right you know what if you could
reword that one maybe maybe I just read
it in a stranger okay let's jump back to
super chat Blaire how do you approach
dating as a trans woman did you have to
come out as trans after beginning a
relationship do you have any advice for
other trans women um advice would be
just to be honest from the jump like
before you even jump before when you're
walking towards the job be honest yeah
because you don't want to put yourself
in a position where you can be hurt you
don't want to put the other person in a
position where they're uncomfortable
always just be honest for me
never had a problem dating I've never
had a problem finding people who are
okay with it
not that I've dated many people I've had
three relationships in my life I've
always and they've all been serious too
but dating I've always met people
through the internet and so a lot of
times we'll just Google we're wide and
it's like yeah but just be honest always
yeah sure
in I mean I don't know we can only go as
personal as you want to go but I just
met your boyfriend seems like a great
guy
does it bring up issues for the person
that you're with as far as family right
like that you he seems like a great guy
and obviously you guys are great
together but that yeah then he almost is
suddenly on him to have to explain
something to family and friends that he
never had to explain before like it just
compounds like a series of issues yeah
it gets complicated I've had good luck
even with that like dating like family
have always been great the cool thing
about his family is that they're
actually like fans of me and they knew
before that's the case that's been like
pretty cool but that's also a unique
position for me it's not the same for
everyone obviously but I mean his
family's great and they they like me so
so the main point of advice there is
always date someone who's family is a
fan of you right right started YouTube
channel start a YouTube channel and get
to it I've seen a couple things about
gender-neutral pronouns anything
specific on that that you want to hit on
people can wanna me call what they want
I don't use them oh really yeah awkward
oh I think you're gonna dig this one
from super chat would you consider
converting to Islam just to watch the
progressives ride from the conflicting
tears that you occupy on the social
victim slash enemy scale that'd be the
biggest I mean I'd F of n e where like
that's crazy I know Lindsay Lohan's a
Muslim now did you know that I heard
about it isn't one now it's crazy
I miss Mean Girls Lindsay do you know
that I've told the story a couple of
times but for about a year I had Lindsay
Lohan's iPod I can't quite explain why I
had it and how it got into my production
I don't want to explain right now I'll
tell you later
oh because they would involve I could
get so much trouble
a lot of Britney Spears ton of Britney
Spears I knew it this is about
it was probably about eight years ago so
like whatever Britney's peak was it was
right around then that's a lot of
Britney Spears but I had Lindsay Lohan's
iPod should assault rifles be banned I'm
not for banning things no fair enough
you sort of addressed this already but
maybe we can whittle it down a little
bit from patreon and regarding military
service do you believe that people that
are transitioning should be allowed on
the frontline so I think it's there's a
couple questions here so I think your
answer was no right my answer was I can
understand the argument I'm having with
you if someone passes all the tests why
not
Brett I think I am I mean I'm not
involved in military right but it's
interesting the way the person wrote
this because they said that are
transitioning so did they didn't say
transition then probably not that's
probably even just like to their own
benefit not the best right because there
could be then physical reason yeah
they're still going through things okay
and then it continues my concern is that
a frontline scenario and their potential
reliance on hormone replacement therapy
that in a wartime scenario they may not
have access to those medications and
risk becoming a danger in terms of trans
suicide rates which turn risks on their
fellow soldiers and they're altered
mental state at the loss of h2 the
hormone replacement therapy that's
interesting that just in the cause of
war adding an extra element where you
need certain yeah if you're reliant on a
medication like that then yeah then I
would say no right I mean if you were on
the frontlines and you needed diabetes
medication yeah that also doesn't work
aids things yeah but then again there's
also so many gray areas cause not all
trans people are on hormones it's all
the gray areas we talked about yeah it's
a lot it's a lot I love this one this is
from Facebook actually teach me how not
to care about other people's opinions
Blair we've hit this a couple times any
other bonus advice on there I would say
stabilize your own life so you're not
reliant on other people's acceptance
because you can have people mad at you
from every angle but if you're living
your life and you're supporting yourself
and you're fine then who cares yeah
just just do your own thing it doesn't
matter you can't get caught up in that I
like it I think I'm gonna I'm gonna pre
say yes to this one can the to you
please have a meet-up in LA you're my
two favorite youtuber
we should do a joint meetup that'd be so
cool all right we will do a joint Meetup
we will discuss the details of that
privately super chat what is your
opinion on the lack of right slash
libertarian arts and cultural output any
current authors the lack of right slash
libertarian output on arts Oh maybe how
art seems to mostly come from the left
yeah I mean it does you look at media
you look at movies music all of that
you're on all that comes from from the
left really that's why especially being
here in Hollywood which is where hope it
all comes from we talked about how
everyone here there's a leftist
basically yeah I would say especially um
the people on the right should maybe get
more monopoly on that same with it's
awfully that with social media how we
shouldn't the right should make more
social media outlets rather when also
always relying on Twitter and stuff so
like on value have like a stranglehold
on all of that so I think it's important
to start diversifying that for sure yeah
it definitely does are you in enthused
though at least how many libertarians or
classical liberals whatever it is are on
YouTube because you see all these these
people young people get on YouTube they
start earning money they start realizing
what they want involved in their life or
not and I see so many of them actually
shifting to libertarianism because of
that so that's at least rather yeah we
may not have enough artists yet yeah
when it comes to YouTube actually um
libertarians and right-wing people and
Republicans actually have a monopoly on
YouTube it's kind of crazy like if you
look at leftist channels they don't do
as well and they get a lot of dislikes
but again that's not real life cuz you
know I can be on YouTube and see a lot
of people saying what I would say and
hold views that I hold I walk down the
street in Hollywood and it's completely
opposite so Hollywood ain't real life
sure ok I think they did reword their
their question so to reword my previous
question do you think sexual orientation
should be based on secondary sexual
characteristics and noticeable cues
instead of sex I know which is something
we can't naturally detect unaided this
would make liking traps or people with
the XY
female syndrome not gay I know what
they're saying
yeah there's they're basically saying
like it's sexual orientation defined by
secondary sex characteristics which is
like your face your body outward rather
than just genitals and I would say that
that's actually kind of how it works
like if you look at one thing I like to
say when people think that it's like
homosexual to be with the trans woman
it's like well it's not the straightest
thing about the gayest thing but also
that if you go you office it's not this
dancing with something because if you
ask them if you look at like a trans man
do you know who buck angel is I do know
about angel I had interviewed him on my
LGBT thing on Sirius XM right so he's a
trans man female to male transsexual and
has a vagina yeah one star porn stars
successful porn star yeah um I don't
think straight men are lining up to [ __ ]
buck angel you know what I mean can I
curse I'm so sorry the first time I
curse I think you want to do it again
okay [ __ ] I don't know yeah straight men
aren't lining up to [ __ ] because he
has a vagina it's more about secondary
sex characteristics of what she has
everything male secondary right now so I
wonder I mean he probably knows but what
who are the people that are mostly
watching that that I don't even want one
of those people identify as kids kind of
really interesting I don't know about
trans men and their porn
that's actually really niche I think but
when it comes to porn of trans women
what I do know is that that porn only
exists on straight websites in the
beginning when transporting first
started becoming a thing if they put it
on gay websites and it didn't do well
they put it on straight websites and it
just boomed that's it I think is that
how this is gonna sound completely
amateur something but is there trans
porn of for guys that have fully
transitioned or at that point why would
you
you mean like male to female like yeah
right
fully resistant bottom and everything
then at that point what would be the
purpose of watching porn of that person
so I know that's got to be a very very
niche yeah if they like fully
transitioned they lose their their
stardom for sure right yeah but but
where you're at would actually be
there's plenty of porn like that I mean
yeah there's plenty yeah I wouldn't get
it though
I've been offered that I'm not trying to
convince you to become a porn star here
that would be that would be quite a way
of doing it okay we're due to do a
couple more minutes here again it's
we're on patreon we're on super chat oh
and we're doing a we're doing a
rapid-fire I don't even tell you but
you're sticking around for a rapid-fire
patrons only
we're I'm just gonna plow through things
that yeah and you're just gonna fit but
after the porn talking in a plow yeah
okay and trust me there's a lot of juicy
stuff there okay a couple people asked
about your modernization situation you
you already said it didn't hit you that
hard and you're sort of surprised by
that actually right yeah I'm definitely
surprised all right we're gonna wrap up
do we have one more here that I feel
like I feel I feel good about this you
feel good about this I feel great all
right in that case all right so here's
we're gonna do we are gonna do the rapid
fire on patreon we're gonna do some sort
of hangout in LA and the four of us are
gonna do dinner but now but I will
evolve no cap you're okay we're doing
something with no cameras right yeah I
don't need dinner on camera that's
double date let's do it yeah all right
awesome
all right well it's been a pleasure and
yes we're doing rapid-fire on patreon
thank you guys for watching and a and I
just this morning taped an interview
with Greg Gutfeld it was really really
fun cool guy and got an interesting
perspective on a guy that's in
mainstream cable news but gets the
online world it was really it was fun to
chat with them so check that out
tomorrow and I'm at Claremont McKenna if
you happen to be outside of LA tonight
all right later
[Music]
you